what's up reject nation last night
gave us the falcon of winter soldier
trailer and of course
as mentioned in the review part of that
video of our reaction
you know where i'm going with this gary
voss the new rockstar breakdown the
easter eggs
want to watch his video i'm sure there's
plenty of things that he's going to be
able to
uncover with his detective skills also
do you want to mention that in our
reaction
it got blocked in some countries because
of the music so if there's any parts
where they like
play some of the footage from the
trailer and it's just music
mainly i'm probably going to lower the
audio just just so it could be
accessible to all countries i don't know
why this keeps happening anyways anyhow
let's do this
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the falcon of the winter
soldier just dropped a new trailer and
for any of you worried that marvel going
forward is all genre bending
with i don't know why you'd worry about
that i personally love
it the falcon of the winter soldier by
comparison is like a boom boom
yeah bass like in the spirit of lethal
weapon and the fast and the furious very
true fun fact a lot of people say
mission impossible hello girl kick your
ass
i'm gonna break down this trailer shot
by shot because there are actually
some insane visual clues telling us how
this series
is going to connect not just to avengers
game and one division it's funny how so
many people including
ourselves are pointing out how this
feels like fast and furious
in so many ways over the top somewhat
convoluted but also yeah just that
family love in the middle
fast and furious and hobbs and shaw
which is part of fascinating it's just
it's pretty strange ironic there are
actually some insane visual clues
telling us how this series
is gonna connect not just to avengers
end game and one division but the future
marvel titles like secret invasion and
x-men and these cap team-up movies that
are being announced let's get started
so who would like to start
mr barnes why does sam aggravate you
15 seconds to drop so what's our plan
great okay we opened on this hilarious
couple counseling
scene they are an unusual couple you
know
notice the music scream
actually my breakdown last year of
captain america winter soldier i pointed
out how the winter soldier music
was composed using this distorted scream
to make that sound the composer
literally screamed in his studio and
used that distorted it stretched it out
kind of like rated it over metal as a
way to not do bucky's
inner torment dating back to his scream
in that fall from the train in the first
cap film
oh no need hydra's clutches
so this is the scream of bucky's buried
rage from being brainwashed by hydra
into a killing machine
by the way one of the same composers
dealing with a similar hydra induced
trauma but this opening clip syncs that
sound effect with sam
diving out of the cargo plane
and in doing so sam is evoking cap from
winter soldier
yeah he wearing a parachute
no no he wasn't you know i'm just kind
of wondering his crossbones gonna come
back
you never know i would never put it
faster i feel like they're bringing back
all these characters that were in the
captain america movies let's get
crossbones back in there why not let's
let's give him some proper justice
i have no intention to leave my work i'm
finished time for him to interpret the
statue
this is madrapore a fictional setting
for the marvel comics located near real
life singapore it's a haven for
criminals in the marvel universe there
is a huge wealth gap
super rich crime lords and the towering
skyscrapers and the bottom feeders in
the street level drug dens
like cyberpunk we've got a disparity in
the vessels in the harbor massive luxury
yachts and more modest fishing boats
madrapore like places like sokovia and
wakanda is the latest new fictional
setting on earth being explored
looks like blade runner this ties to the
x-men and wolverine as well as to the
hands of the enemies of daredevil and
iron fist
it's really exciting that we're going
there but now that one division appears
to be bringing in
quick silver from the fox x-men universe
the mcu might have more of a multiverse
explanation in mind for how
mutants are coming into the mcu there's
a couple other explanations for what's
going on there i got a whole other video
coming out about it tomorrow keep an eye
out for it
continues
from captivity i'm gonna try not to only
cover new rockstars videos this weekend
you gotta follow the glee damn
excitement
the blip because one division just
showed us that the snap's reversal
without warning
resulted in total chaos across the
universe if a hospital could be suddenly
overrun
so could whatever prison facilities zemo
was being kept in
actually remember the last trailer
showed a shot of what looked like a
simmering prison riot
guards overwhelmed that could have been
that post-split moment
another possibility could have been
released by thunderbolt ross and some
plot by ross to create a thunderbolts
team of anti-heroes similar to zemo's
citizen the arc and the thunderbolts
comics we'll see if they end up going in
that direction but here's zemo's
sounds like the likely statue actually
you know i am
thinking to myself that it could be more
of the thunderbolt ross letting him out
there's a rumor going around that
florence pew
is supposed to show up in this series as
well as well as hawkeye too
so this should tie into black widow okay
and thunderbolt ross's in black widow
so i could see that being a little bit
more of the likely scenario versus the
post blip scenario although it would be
cool if it's all tying into post split
but i don't know if then i feel a little
repetitive yeah
yeah i mean it's an important event and
we are picking up after that but it's
always going to be interesting to see
what their lives feel like
post blip but i do think it'd be a
little bit more menacing
if you do have it be thunderbolt ross
that's just that's my preferred pick it
would be propulsive that way
think about it everyone else in the
world just got reunited with their lost
loved ones from the blip but not zemo
his family remains dead damn superheroes
couldn't save my family
except loki he's always the exception of
the rule let's move on
okay tell me who these people are
the waters are back
where do we start here bucky going by
mcu ball cap rules
you know i just know this cap was on his
left ah
the couch every time anyone's left i'm
gonna
best disguise no one's gonna recognize
him he's watching this military awards
ceremony now i'm thinking this could be
the moment john walker gets promoted to
u.s
agent he gets the shield notice how sam
wears a non-military suit and he looks
wistfully from the shield to cap's
exhibit in the smithsonian he doesn't
want to give it away
forced to participate in the ceremony to
take the shield from the exhibit and
hand it over begrudgingly oh
that series appears to be sounds like it
was actually cast in an unknown role and
many believe it's going to be the
historical black cap
isaiah bradley an african-american test
subject for the super soldier serum
before it was given to steve rogers
during world war ii
the guy who had this whole other history
that never gave its proper due
and maybe now sam has to grapple with
that history of black erasure
also if lumbly is isaiah bradley that
could set up a younger actor to play his
grandson elijah bradley the young
avenger patriots
notice how sam looks up to the mural of
cap that
is to the left of him come on
here i love how the editing syncs up
that's about as far as my easter eggs
are just tossing a frisbee makes it feel
like great teamwork you know bucky's
catch and recoil kind of evokes caps
catch and recoil of mjolnir and in-game
yeah here we go again huh
here this club's painting collection
includes van gogh's famous self-portrait
that belongs in a museum
i wonder if during the blip looters
could have stolen famous art from
museums and then it all ended up in the
hands of rich collectors like this
sam says he has a plan in this great
close-up that matches the framing of
iron man's hud close-ups now it's not
sure what sam's plan
is though this mission looks like he and
bucky had to liberate this plane from
combatants first
so they might be stealing it or stealing
whatever's on it or stealing
from the hijackers and sharon carter is
confirmed to be back from civil war so
glad to have her back especially since
she
is at the top of my list of hidden
government scrolls in the mcu why am i
bringing up scrolls
really seeing the next clip scrolls
that shot at the game is is like the
perfect
reason they they have to show this at
the super bowl
it's just like the perfect super bowl
commercial but we have to bite that time
now
huge detail from this section this wall
of skulls
and the reactions those are scrolls
huh so whoever runs this club they
hunt scrolls and they use their freaking
decoration
awesome so the secret invasion is oh
we're
building and they don't like them
squirrels showed up on jimmy wu's notes
so we know the war that is coming
and spider-man far from home
which begs the question if falcons tech
is this awesome and functional does he
really need
cap shield that's why i hope he gets to
just stay falcon but that shield could
end up in the hands of neither bucky nor
sam
but really maybe the bradley family and
right before the explosion in the
shipping yard you can
see zemo standing on a crate he is
wearing his purple mask high collar coat
four figures are standing below each
with a different look
so zemo is commanding some team in this
series
maybe the mcu's version of the
thunderbolts maybe something else we'll
see
i think it's the thunderbolts more shots
of this truck sequence two red trucks
maybe some kind of heist back doors are
open there you can see bucky being
restrained on one sam on the other as
aaron kellerman's character watches this
group is probably her group the flag
smashers based on the cat villain who
wants to unite the world by tearing down
national flag iconography
she jump punches bucky off the side of
the truck and as falcons swoops in under
both trucks it looks as though you could
see him catching bucky there so
bucky appears to win this staring
contest as the winter soldier he was
brainwashed to like never flinch
i love how when that woman snaps sam
looks over but
bucky doesn't the winter soldier is
frozen
and she jokes how old are you and i love
bucky's response because yeah old
how old well in my reaction my quick
math was 101
since he was born in 1917 and then he
flipped in 2018 making him 101 and then
five years later he didn't age so
assuming this takes place not long after
end game he'd either be like 101 or 102.
but this is complicated because remember
most of the 20th century he was on
ice he would just be thought out time to
time by hydra to assassinate somebody so
bucky doesn't really know how old he is
he just knows you're super old maybe
upwards of 100.
but i bet he's not a virgin i bet he got
laid before
the war oh yes i bet he did absolutely
i yeah he had a girlfriend actually at
the beginning of that movie let's see
he's getting late now now yeah
one woman man one woman yeah for the
rest of his natural days
the revelation of the scrolls on the
wall you know when you get captain
marvel
and all that dealing with the scrolls
the announcement of secret invasion
you get the post-credits scene we're far
from home we still don't know what the
hell nick fury's doing up there yeah
jimmy wu does say are they scrolls kind
of like
are they a villainous threat of sorts
rumor
theory i think eric voss is actually the
one who presented it is that
monica rambo's aerospace engineer friend
might be the scroll
from captain marvel when monica rambo
was a little girl and that was a little
girl scroll
with that in mind i feel like what we're
secretly building to is secret invasion
like in a real subtle way like these
little
clues throughout of like no we're going
to
secret invasion and that's the big thing
we're building to right now not
not avengers 5 it's secret invasion
yeah really peeling back the layers and
uncovering that and the scope of it
through
some of these shows it seems like
perhaps especially through falcon and
the winter soldier
i know man it's gonna be cool i mean
loki's has a good shot of tying it in
two and this girl's
probably more likely to keep talking
about history
yeah exactly the other part that i
really love about this is
you know he's talking about black cap
the one before uh i think that's isaiah
bradley the one before
they tested on steve rogers and then
he's not even mentioned none of that's
been confirmed for here but i hear this
show is gonna
actually deal with some political
commentary on both sides of the argument
which i find very interesting i think
that would
be appropriate for something that deals
with the legacy of captain america
and out of anything in the franchises of
the mcu the captain america world is the
one where you can do it
i mean it wouldn't go as like heavy or
as deep
i imagine as something like how watchmen
did it because that was like an
r-rated series for hbo but you know if
they are dealing with those kind of
consequences
as well as you know all the other things
you can really touch on
pulling from today pretty cool man
there's a lot to uncover here anyway
guys what are you most excited about for
falcon and winter soldier leave your
thoughts down below i'm really itching
for that quicksilver video though
so i got some i got some i'm my plan is
to write down my theories and then see
if any of them
he brings up guys subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
check out new rockstars videos they got
so many wonderful videos that we do not
react to there's a gazillion of them
that are all great check them out
last but not least
tyler hague tyler my man you um
contracted the thing oh buddy and i'm
sorry about that
but but you have officially defeated a
sad thing
dude well done i'm proud of you man you
hulk smashed
that virus to death that's what you did
dude yeah like a real american hero a
real
american heel your body shielded itself
oh yeah
from the terror of what that thing is
yeah you
you get to skip the sword of vaccination
for the old
school method that is very
impressive i don't know how you beat
herpes man
dude it's really important
ever to have done that share that with
with the with the both of us just want
to let you know i love you
i'm glad you're safe and now you could
pour yourself around this valentine
no protection be safe with no protection
my man